one is whether the principal commitment
to human rights that exists in many
governments around the world can survive
the very real threat of terrorism that
also exists today um and there is a
temptation that we've seen indulged in
many instances to sacrifice rights in
the name of protecting us from terrorism
it is a strategy that I think is not
only wrong but also short-sighted
because it loses the moral high ground
which is just what the terrorists want
in order to accentuate the divide to
facilitate their recruitment to
discourage public cooperation with law
enforcement efforts these are all
consequences of ignoring human rights
but it has not been enough to convince
the US government and certain key
European allies that they should resist
the temptation to sacrifice rights as an
expedient in the name of fighting
terrorism so that's one thing I worry
about the other thing I worry about is
the willingness on the part of the world
to make real sacrifices to come to the
aid of people who are facing mass
atrocities at the end of the 1990s we
saw the emergence of what is sometimes
known as the doctrine of the
responsibility to protect others call it
humanitarian intervention but the
willingness on the part of governments
around the world to step in even to the
extent of using military force if that
was necessary to stop a genocide to stop
mass slaughter and much as I think any
of us resist the idea of going to war if
at all possible in my view pacifism is
not the ultimate value there are times
when war is necessary and one of those
would be when people are standing
helplessly before a government that is
mowing them down and at that stage they
look in my view the international
community
duty to step in